theo dệ phụi chế biến và xuất hầu thủy sản Việt Nam sau tháng đầu năm 2021.
Ngành thủy sản Việt Nam khi nhận sự phục khuổi mạnh mẽ với kiên nạch xuất hầu đặt năm 2019
từ lạ Mỹ, tăng Mì chính phẩy năm 2019 xong 2020.
Tồng sản lượng thủy sản đặt khoảng 4.5 triệu tấn, tăng Bà về 1.5 triệu.
Trong đó, thủy sản khai thác đặt 1 phẩy chi mấy bẩy triệu tấn,
thủy sản đui trồng đặt hai phẩy năm 2019.
Trong tháng 7, xuất hầu thủy sản đặt khoảng chiến trâm bẩy mốt triệu 2020
tăng sau phẩy 1 phẩy năm 2020.
Lối kế bẩy tháng đầu năm nay, kiên nạch xuất hầu thủy sản của nước tài đặt khoảng
6.5 triệu 2019 tăng Mì bẩy 2 phẩy 5.5 suốt ki.
Tồng thủy tục làm mặt tháng xuất hầu chú lực, đặt hai phẩy 1 miế chính tủy
2019 tăng 2018 phẩy sản phẩy năm 2020.
Puy nhiên, thi chương hoa ki, chiến tì trọng lớn, đang gặp thích thức lớn
sò chính sách thủy quan mới khiến đơn thàng của dân nghiệp có giấu hiệu chính là.
Dự báo, năm 2020, kiên nạch xuất hầu tôn của nước tà có thể đặt má phẩy sấu đến
bà phẩy tám tỷ do lầm miếp, nếu các dành nghiệp tức tục khai thác tốt thị trường cho
a, e u và các nước thình viên hiệp định đối tác bản dẫn và tiến bộ sinh thái bình dường.
Nếu các thị trường lớn thử lợi, tính cả năm 2020, kiên nạch xuất hầu thủy sản của Việt Nam
có thể đặt khoảng chiến đến chính phẩy 2 tỷ do lầm miếp, giảm gần 1 phẩy 5.5.